الفرق الليبية والدولية
تعمل بلا كلل في البحر لمحاولة
انتشال جثث الآلاف من
ضحايا الحدث الكارثي الذي وقع الأسبوع الماضي
والذي ضرب مدينة الضنة وقد
رأينا الفرق الليبية هنا أه تحاول
قصارى جهدها لمحاولة الخروج إلى البحر
لمحاولة الوصول إلى جثث هؤلاء
الضحايا ولكن ما نسمعه من
الفرق الدولية التي
تعمل على ذلك منذ أيام هو أن
هذه أصبحت مهمة شبه مستحيلة،
ويقولون إن أحد الفرق أخبرنا
أنهم تمكنوا من التعافي  أكثر من
60 جثة منذ أن وصلوا إلى هنا لكنهم
الآن غير قادرين على القيام بذلك بعد الآن،
يقول هذا الفريق أنهم رصدوا أه
جثث حوالي 300 شخص ولكن
الظروف صعبة للغاية
بالنسبة لهم ويقولون إنهم ليس لديهم
المعدات المناسبة للوصول إلى هذه
المناطق التي يصعب الوصول إليها، حيث
انتهى الأمر بهذه الجثث إلى
المياه الضحلة حيث يمكن لقواربهم أن تذهب،
وليس لديهم المعدات
والخبرة والقوى العاملة للتعامل مع
موقف مثل هذا وما يفعلونه.  ما
يخبرنا به هو أنه بينما اكتشفوا هذه
الجثث خلال اليومين الماضيين،
تفككت هذه الجثث
إلى بقايا لا
يمكنهم الوصول إليها ولا يمكنهم استعادتها
بسبب المخاطر الصحية، وهذا أمر
مدمر للغاية للعديد من
العائلات الناجية هنا  دونا الذي
كان يتحدث إليه والذين أخبرونا أن كل ما
يريدونه هو العثور على جثث
أحبائهم أو رفاتهم لمنحهم
دفنًا مناسبًا، هذا
الفريق الدولي الذي تحدثنا معه سابقًا قال
إنهم تعاملوا مع حوادث في
الماضي  مع انقلاب قوارب المهاجرين،
تعاملوا مع عمليات البحث والانتشال
حيث تمكنوا من انتشال
العشرات من الجثث في الماضي ولكن لم
يضطروا أبدًا إلى التعامل مع موقف بشيء
على نطاق واسع من قبل حيث
يبحثون عن المئات
والآلاف  جثث
CNN دنا ليبيا